Browns at Texans I think the Browns Edge
it out they just have so much on that
defense CJ's very limited to the weapons
he has right now because of the injuries
I have to go with the Browns in week one
Dolphins at Chiefs losing Bradley chub
jayen Phillips these injuries are just
killing the Dolphins I'm going to
continue to go with the dolphins because
the Chiefs struggle offensively I'm
afraid those turnovers them drops will
cost them this game Steelers at bills I
think the bills is trending in a right
way just seeing TJ Watts out they're in
Josh's house is going to had to go
builds we got Eagles bucks I don't know
too much about the Eagles right now
especially with jaylen's finger Baker
Mayfield has been playing good ball
their defense has been playing great
ball we have to go Bucks but I think the
Eagles have more time they can get
through this adversity they can easily
beat the Bucks Rams at lions lions have
the number one run defense it's going to
be the question can they get stops
against the Rams I'mma have to go Rams
and that leads us to Packers Cowboys yes
I said Jordan is a friend of mine but we
are not friends on Sunday this is going
to be a great matchup